we're going to talk about sidoku and in
particular something called The fistel
Ring fistel Ring well it's named after a
German sodoku Constructor called fisel
uh who discovered it a couple of years
ago and it's a property that exists in
all soku puzzles but not many people
know about it and it's it's got a quite
a lovely proof and it might blow your
mind it might all right it might is it
use like is this like a a secret that
will help people solve sedus it can
definitely help help you solve some
sedus and yeah maybe should I show you
so maybe while I'm doing this I'll tell
you I'm sure everybody watching number
file knows the rules of sodoku the idea
of sidoku is you have to put the numbers
1 to n just once each into every row
every column and into every 3x3
box that is our sidoku and what I'm
going to show you now is something
called set equivalence Theory so we know
that in this sidoku if we complete it
correctly there'll be the numbers 1 to n
once each in every row column and box so
I'm now going to highlight some cells in
Red so I'm going to highlight Row three
row seven this box this whole box here
and box six and the interesting thing
about those those four things I just
highlighted is because of the properties
of sidoku we actually know we don't know
what the disposition of the digits will
be within those red cells but we do know
exactly what those red cells contain Al
together because it's four complete sets
of the digits 1 to 9 one for this Row
one for this Row one for this box and
one for this box so Al together we know
that the red cells here contain four
sets of the digits 1 to N9 now I'm going
to switch to green and I'm going to
highlight a different four sets of the
digits 1 to n so I'm going to highlight
the whole oh can we see that that's
green so I'm going to highlight the
whole of column one the hole of column
two the hole of column 8 and the hole of
column
9 okay so now let's describe the the the
green set of digits that's also four
sets of the digits 1 to n one for each
of the columns so at this point we know
that the set of the green cells if you
like and the set of the red cells are
identical each equal to four sets of the
digits 1 to N9 now the trick to
understanding the fist ofl ring is to
focus on one of these cells that has two
colors in it so let's look at this cell
here and imagine that we removed it from
both the green set and the red set so
let's let's imagine that we we just take
this out I'll make it blue so I'm
removing this from both the green set
and the red set what can we say about
the remaining cells now in green and red
and the thing we can say is that they
still contain the same set of digits we
don't know now exactly what that set of
digits is because we don't know what
digit will F fill in row three column 1
in the final solution but we do know
that the red set and the green set are
still equivalent they're still equal and
we can do that for every single every
single cell in this puzzle that contains
both colors we can remove it from both
the green set and the red set let's now
focus on what we've got left now so we
know at this point that the green and
the red set sets are still equivalent
and if we look at the red set you can
see 16 cells here ringing the central
box of the sidoku now this is the fist
ofel ring and we know that that is
exactly the same digits as appear in the
four corners of the soku these four 2 by
tws in the corners and you can try this
on any sidoku you solve on your train
home fill it in and then ring this
Central box and compare those digits to
the corners 2 by tws and you will find
that this works it works for every soku
and it's I think it's quite
[Music]
magical one of the questions that pops
into my head is could you make any other
shapes or configurations on a grid that
have this property Brady you are
brilliant yeah yes you can indeed um and
in fact there's a famous Dutch
Constructor called AR van Deering who he
found another trick he found that
there's a a a square in the top left of
a sidoku and a square in the bottom
right of the sidoku that have a
relationship using exactly this trick
and we've even seen puzzles now where
you can use this feature to create the
difference of squares equation in sedu
form it sounds completely crazy but you
can see it on the screen here and you
can create some mathematics out of the
geometry of sidoku that actually can
yield to some really beautiful results
so and it's very very much in in sort of
really Advanced soku solving this
equivalence of different parts of the
geometry of the grid is important and
can be it can crack some fish
puzzles check the links on screen and
Below to see another video about that
mathematical sidoku that Simon just
mentioned and to see Simon and his
offside of Mark solving all sorts of
puzzles check out their amazing YouTube
channel cracking the cryptic again links
below thanks for watching this video and
thank you to our patreon supporters
you're seeing some of their names on the
screen at the moment and you can also
see me signing these unique primes in
the post I'll be mailing these out to
most of our supporters later this month
what prime number will you get I might
even send twin primes to some
people